Michael do you believe even though
there's no evidence right now that these
attacks may have been coordinated well
as you say there is no evidence of
coordination but there is evidence of
inspiration meaning that part of what
diache or Isis has done is it has
counseled or advised people who believe
in its ideology to go carry out attacks
and so it's not a coincidence it
reflects a kind of commonality of
ideology behind all these attacks
michael chertoff talk about France it's
been the site of many terror-related
attacks well the French have a
significant population of people who
have immigrated from the middle easter
or parts of africa some part of that
population a small part but still a
significant part is either radicalized
or at least sympathetic to
radicalization and we've seen some of
these people carry out these attacks
both in the Charlie Hebdo case and in
what we saw today and in fact according
to news reports the authorities were
actually monitoring one of the
perpetrators of today's attack over a
period of time several years ago and I
think this reflects the concern that
many Western countries have and that
Isis will use people who are citizens or
residents of those countries as being
part of the attack vector against
innocent civilians and that makes it and
that makes it Michael much more
complicated and it much more difficult i
believe to to try to preempt them so
what does France do then to try to make
sure that they secure the country well
you're right it's very challenging
because you have a very large pool of
potential terrorists there's a limit to
the resources that any law enforcement
agency has it's one of the reasons that
we do pay a lot of attention to our
ability to collect intelligence you know
some of the programs that get criticized
are exactly the programs that allow you
to identify and spot people who may be
connected to a terrorist group so you
can stop an attack but I think we're
going to see
more of this and there's one other
significant thing here it was an
American company that was attacked in
France and in Tunisia was a tourist
hotel and for Americans who are
traveling overseas what that's going to
mean is they have to be more and more
careful that they may be at risk in
third countries and that's part of what
we need to start thinking about also
need to start thinking about Isis in
Kuwait tell us about that well the
attack there of course was on a Shia
religious facility and it's very similar
to what we saw in the last couple of
months in Saudi Arabia and there the
agenda is a little different I think
they're the of Isis leadership wants to
provoke a fight with the Shia and create
basically a sectarian war we actually
saw some of that going back almost 10
years ago when Zarqawi who headed the
al-qaeda group interacted the same thing
he attacked Shia institutions and
mosques as part of a way of a striking
against what he viewed as an apostate
group so we see these terrorists
operating on multiple fronts focusing on
Westerners including Americans but also
focusing on the internal battle between
Sunni and Shia factions within Iraq and
and other parts of the Middle East
Michael how likely are we going to see
you know taking the example of what
happened in Tunisia for example I mean
how likely could we see that happen here
on US soil well obviously we've seen a
number of attempted attacks in the u.s.
we've seen other tax disrupted by the
way the notion of attacking a hotel
where they're tourists is something we
saw back in in Mumbai in 2008 right so I
do think we're going to see soft targets
increasingly being targeted by the
current generation of terrorists I'm
that's not to say they won't try another
big attack like 911 but as we've
degraded them over time I think they're
finding it easier now to bring multiple
attacks against multiple easier targets
attacks on the United Nations
peacekeeping troops in Somalia
well that's right you and again another
thing we've seen is historically
terrorists attack NGOs or charitable
organizations because they view these
organizations as potentially winning the
allegiance of the local populace and
what the terrorists want to do is have a
monopoly of power in the areas they
control they want to use force to
intimidate and then to the extent that
they're going to be benefits given out
they want to have the ability to control
the benefits and reward those who are
part of their group Michael before we go
so what is what should be happening
right now knowing that within the last
you know 24 hours really we've seen
these attacks in four different
countries what needs to be happening now
among the intelligence agencies in in
all of those countries and here in the
US as well and in the end in Europe well
I think the intelligence agencies need
to make sure they are sharing in real
time current information about people
who are potential threats out there and
I think you know the word is going to
have to go out and I know it's gone out
here in the US to people who whether
it's hotel owners or people who have
other infrastructure or other kinds of
public facilities they need to make sure
they've got a plan in place to raise
security almost on a moment's notice and
a lot of that is not a just prevention
its response if somebody does wind up in
a shopping mall or a hotel you've got to
have the ability with a local law
enforcement to very very quickly shut
that down otherwise you can have a
horrible tragedy like you had in Mumbai
almost ten years ago where the
terrorists had 60 hours of mayhem before
they were finally killed or apprehended